foreign
there had been an idea floating around
that depression
was a manifestation of a pure deficit in
serotonin lower serotonin you get
depressed take a Prozac you get
underpressed we knew that idea was wrong
right from the start because you take a
tablet of Prozac you do not get
underpressed from a single tablet or
Prozac it can happen it's
extraordinarily rare doesn't and it
usually doesn't last when that occurs
but the world is really complicated and
uh maybe we'll come back to it and
what's complicated is
that serotonin does have a lot of acute
effects in the brain and a single dose
of Prozac does change some things so for
example Catherine harmer at the
University of Oxford in the United
Kingdom has done a large number of
studies to show that some of the
negative biases that people have
when they're depressed go away
at least transiently with a single dose
of Prozac so it's not that there aren't
some acute effects and that those
effects aren't related to depression
it's just that this simple-minded idea
that low depression low serotonin equals
depression normal serotonin equals a
healthy life that idea is
we knew pretty much from the start
couldn't possibly
be true as it was initially suggested
the other thing I'll say just before
moving on because there's a tendency to
want to make the world simple
either it's all serotonin or it's no
serotonin but as I said would the most
complex structure in the universe really
work in such a simple-minded way that it
had to be everything or nothing probably
not
and there are brain scan studies in
depression involving positron emission
tomography the work of people like Ramin
Parsi and and others that do find some
changes in the regulation of certain
serotonin receptors that may be
intrinsic to the biology of depression
so I'm not in any way arguing for a
really simple-minded idea of depression
but I do want to highlight that these
these
monoamine depletion studies were
a
conceptual crisis like the philosopher
Thomas Kuhn would say you come to a
point where you have a body of theory
and then you have a single experiment
which in a fundamental way challenges
the idea that this idea that's
depression is simply a disorder of the
very primitive and very few number of
Serotonin cells that live in a very
primitive part of the brain the midbrain
a little bit of the brain stem that
these
primitive cells could be the cause of
this pervasive syndrome of cognitive
behavioral and
Etc et cetera impairment
probably was
you know just that idea itself was
probably flawed from the start
but like all conceptual crises
it
was incredibly stimulating in terms of
creative thought about what the
alternatives
ideas about depression work and and so
in those days when these experiments
were going on Dennis Charney who was the
my now my boss as well as my
collaborator his office was upstairs on
the ninth floor he had a really good
view of Long Island Sound and I had a
little office on the eighth floor and
you know I would go up at the end of the
day and we would talk about science and
all the things that are going on and we
wrestled with this this is one of the
things that we wrestled with a lot if it
wasn't serotonin simply
what could it be right
and
the answer was that we came to us let's
turn the brain on on its head gosh
that's a really weird turn of phrase but
let's turn this problem upside down if
depression isn't a disorder of these
really simple and few
serotonin cells in the brain then maybe
it's a disorder
that has a major part of its biology in
the parts of the brain that are
responsible for regulating emotion for
processing reward for making plans for
interpreting the world
in other words the higher cognitive
centers like the cortex cerebral cortex
and the higher emotional centers in the
limbic system
and there was a profound
consequence of that small conceptual
shift
because the cortex in the limbic system
are predominantly driven by different
chemical Messengers
then serotonin and arpinephrine
serotonin and norepinephrine tune and
and modulate the activities of the
higher brain centers but it pulled us to
think about
the intrinsic circuit mechanisms of the
cortex and limbic system and to try to
approach those circuits directly with
pharmacology these higher brain centers
predominantly use two neurotransmitters
glutamate which accounts for something
like 90 percent of the synapses of the
brain right
the main information Highway the brain
ninety percent of the synapses the main
excitatory driver for brain activity
and Gaba which is the main inhibitory
transmitter of the cortex
the function of the cerebral cortex and
limbic system is essentially a dynamic
tension like yin and yang between
factors driving excitation
and the magnitude of excitation and the
timing of excitation and the spatial
dispersion of activity in the brain
and Gaba balancing and inhibition
and we thought well
gee
how can we tap into
signaling through the main information
Highway the brain and it's really
remarkable isn't it serotonin is maybe a
couple of percentages of the synapses in
the brain
glutamate is 90
Psychiatry have been studying depression
for 50 years by that point
put all of its chips on serotonin and
norepinephrine the two percent and
completely ignoring the 98 of the other
mechanisms in the brain so we thought
well let's
try that so
by that time I had been studying for at
least five years I had been studying
ketamine to try to understand its role
in synaptic signaling in disorders
problems cognitive processes Behavior
other things related to schizophrenia
and we thought well we can use ketamine
to probe the Integrity of glutamate
synaptic signaling that's been what I've
been working on for the last five years
let's bring that into testing depression